mashed potatoes Thanksgivings all about
Turkey all about various cranberries
houses but when it comes to the real
hero of Thanksgiving and pretty much any
meal all year round its mashed potatoes
right here I have 11 boxes of this
variety I have 19 boxes of these Idahoan
potatoes all powdered and dehydrated all
they're waiting for is some water some
butter and maybe a spots of milk if
you're feeling sassy and I've got some
gravy here with which I'm going to top
this deliciousness that is my bathtub
and then we celebrate the true meaning
of Thanksgiving so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna open all these I'm gonna put
them in this bathtub I'm gonna mix it up
with some hot water
hopefully water sound by the time it's
in this it's gonna be cold potatoes and
no one's cold potatoes and then baby we
got a stew going except with potatoes
we got master we got potato stew going
yeah Colby stuff LeBron so we're gonna
be putting these mashed potatoes in this
bathtub and the only way to do that is
with brute force a delicate hand if
anyone decided that brute force was
their first thought going into this
potatoes they don't know one of these
things doesn't belong
check out those flicks mmm that's some
meaty texture huh now ordinarily I'd be
using full potatoes but there's a
drought going on the potatoes of this
harvest just dried up didn't have a
chance but I don't care about the
environment so I'm just gonna
go to town on this one
Shaq DeMarcus Cousins Bill Clinton
[Music]
hmm okay so take a look at this madness
that I've created right here this is
what roughly 35 pounds of potatoes looks
like doesn't look like much on its
surface but it's just brimming with
potential yeah there's some people that
like slime channels that just rub all
over slime me like my taters but you
gotta wonder will this turn into slime
if I don't get the ratio of water right
you'd be perfectly honest I don't even
know if there's water gonna be warm the
first time it comes out of the faucet
but the only way to do that is you got
to test it from within there's like a
dust layer on you it's like you've been
in here for a thousand years
all right so we got to get in there whoo
that's like a beach it feels like I'm on
the beach hand me that bucket there I
wanted to make sure that I got the right
temperature quickly like the high funk
this down that's warm
all right baby oh that's warm all right
okay it's fine come this is warm so I
just gotta like guesstimate based on
live interaction of the
potatoes in the water right this is
potater welcome to taylor town you know
mater from the Cars movie I think you
see where I'm going with this oh that's
a smell ah you know when your brain
smells something new and it goes danger
that's what I'm getting right now yeah
believe it or not I've never actually
made some taters of this quantity before
oh then I fed my in-laws you know they
say the sense of smell is the strongest
memory I'm gonna be on my deathbed I'm
gonna try to think of my family time to
click like my friends all the good
memories I'm just gonna have a flashback
to me in a bathtub full of mashed
potatoes
I can't tell if that's gonna be a good
memory or a bad memory soon oh well
sorry loved ones you've been replaced oh
not good stuff but it's death stuff
this is a thing that I've chosen to do
okay I'm gonna put I'm gonna put a pause
on the water flow real quick just cuz I
want to see this looks like and has the
consistency of what both goes in and
comes out of a baby oh oh the grunting
doesn't make this any less awkward oh
did I mention that this video is gonna
be completely disgusting because I I
swear I promised myself that I would
mention that at the beginning as like a
warning Christmas can't wait ah
the Potomac no look up the dam I'm like
the little Dutch boy
I like that weird kid on the side of the
road that makes my stairs out of a
bathtub I'm like markiplier doing
something stupid again oh yeah do I have
potato soup yet or is this some sort of
whisk herbal substance some more well
I'm out of breath and I do believe that
I'm probably gonna start sweating soon
which is just gonna add to the flavor it
always needs a little more salt but with
oh it's like pulling the sword from the
Stone
but in Ireland and that you didn't think
that you're gonna be watching this today
have fun deleting this from your
browsing history this whisk is fine see
now it's got a delightful la halo cuz
it's dead
that's the POTUS 'kiss [ __ ] I I have now
cemented myself in place but the good
news is non-existent this is the worst
thing that I've ever done I have reached
a new low this is not what I meant but
better content you know it's a weirdest
thing these potatoes are both slippery
and like cement which means that either
mashed potatoes are lubricant or the
opposite of that a friction and a stick
inant
am a Googler and died in a bathtub full
of evidence if I fall and die in a
bathtub of mashed potatoes
I mean honestly that Aviv a bit I mean
it's not the worst way to end so we've
reached a juncture it's it's looking a
lot like mashed potatoes except with an
additives of a few other fluids and
substances that weren't originally meant
for potatoes but that's okay we here at
markiplier HQ
like the eMeter the vape and always push
ourselves higher and farther to reach
the lowest point on the Internet
ah that handle will never be the same
okay
ah that's that's not right you know even
though I've not cursed at all in this
video or made any sort of reference I'm
willing to bet this video is gonna get D
monetized but but but big whompin what's
we I've got good potato here now when
you can really when it jiggles back at
you that's when you know you got a good
mash what what what you ask me if that's
a but that's the Millennium Falcon dole
gotcha hon your dad okay so we got
mashed potatoes but that's only half of
the equation because the rest of the
equation is in the grave okay clean
we've got a bucket which as we all know
is the first step to good gravy and
we've got instant gravy which I like and
everything in my life to be as
instantaneous as possible I ain't gonna
wait for [ __ ]
[Music]
can you play the same strategy I used
for the the UH the the what you may lose
it so the hot chocolate
you gotta like bag them open yeah you
can only go like two at a time you just
kind of like into the bags
[Music]
you know I think that's my problem like
my brain and even like my mouth can be
screaming at me no Marc don't do that
you stupid idiot it's not the right way
or that idea is really dumb I think I
just revved me on my forehead but my
body just automatically is like oh you
wanna you want to open them all and then
have to do it all one ahead time even
slower than you would have done it
before because I can't even get this one
alright so what we have here is a bucket
of slop looks a lot like vomit cuz it's
pretty close now I don't know how much
water is necessary for this to become
true gravy but I think I know good gravy
when I see it okay I'm almost positive I
added too much water I'm almost a
hundred percent it's not supposed to
look like chocolate milk actually that
doesn't look like chocolate milk that
looks like toilet water that smells good
smells like dinner's on you know I'd
like to think that my channel can go
from one day being completely wholesome
and innocent and the next day being
literally an idea that a toddler would
come up with and then go home that was a
bad idea me I better not do that so when
I'm eating my mashed potatoes I'd like
to do what I think a lot of people like
to do and that's form a caldera now a
caldera is the landscape that forms
after a volcano has erupted so think of
the mashed potatoes has already been
exploded out of everywhere it leaves
this gap in the middle and over time
that caldera can turn into a lake when
you have gravy
introduce to the minutes this is the
greatest thing I've ever done okay
mysterious happenings the gravy is
draining somewhere I don't know where I
may have somehow created a magic smell a
magic spell that created a portal into
another dimension
you know how in Minecraft you put the
nether bricks around something and then
you just light it with a flint and
somehow it magically turns into a portal
into the nether this is a portal into
the realm of gravy
all right well dimensions into
otherworldly realms of gravy aside I
think what we have here is a delicious
treat that can't be beat you know I've
uh I've eaten some pretty terrible
things in my life I've eaten the pig
testicle I've done hot sauce challenges
I've eaten many peppers
that is pretty up there this is what I
imagine Matt Damon had to eat when he
was trapped on Mars for a year well you
know I didn't get this potato to eat
potatoes have many uses first and
foremost of which is it's incredible for
the skin and if you just get enough oh
mmm
relaxing no that is what I call a good
day mm-hmm okay all right
somehow this like you wouldn't think
that this would be grosser than the hot
chocolate challenge or you might exactly
think so anyway that is the bathtub
mashed potato thing that I did happy
Thanksgiving everybody I hope you all
understood the true meaning of this
holiday and what it means to give thanks
for all that you have in life
but what it means to give thanks to
every opportunity that comes your way
you know you can conquer anything if you
believe in yourself so if you come up
with this thought don't do it just don't
some things some lessons are taught to
you to not do bad things happen to good
people because they need to learn from
the experience and then grow as an
individual so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you
Oh get to the shower
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]